SECTOR.
ONLY 4 MILES OF FENCING.
AND THAT WASN'T ALL.
I WAS HER VAPOR -- SURVEY LINK
THE BORDER FROM THE AIR, THEY
ILLEGAL CROSSING TO THE RIVER,
FLOATED AND LUCKILY RAYMOND
ARROYO IN THE STAFF WAS THERE
WITH THE BORDER PATROL TO
CAPTURE A LOT OF THE DRAMA
>> Raymond: HE IS JUMPING IN
THERE AND READY TO CROSS.
WHERE WOULD YOU INTERSECT THEM?
>> THE MINUTE THEY START GETTING
INTO DISTRESS.
>> Raymond: THIS IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
THIS IS A FATHER.
>> A FATHER AND A CHILD.
>> Raymond: HE'S IN THE WATER
AND THE BABY HAS THE DEVICE ON.
GET OVER HERE.
THIS IS TERRIFYING.
IF A MAN GET SEPARATED, NOW, YOU
HAVE A MAN SEPARATED FROM HIS
BABY.
THE BABY IS CRYING ON THE OTHER
BOAT AND BORDER PATROL IS LEFT
TO HAVE TO FISH HIM OUT OF THE
RIVER.
AND THIS HAPPENS EVERY DAY.
>> EVERYDAY, ALL THE TIME, SUNUP
TO SUNDOWN.
WHEN THE BOATS ARE IN HERE, THEY
ARE DOING THIS PRETTY MUCH
NONSTOP.
>> Raymond: WHY RISK LIFE AND
LIMB?
>> MANY DON'T WANT TO WAIT.
THEY CAN ONLY CROSS HOW MANY A
DAY AND IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT
BRIDGE THEY ARE, THEY ARE TIRED
AND THEY DON'T WANT TO WAIT.
>> Laura: THE MAIN CRISIS, THE
HUMANE CRISIS IN CRISIS TO
HUMANITY FORCING THESE PEOPLE
HERE AND THAT IT'S CREATED, A
NETWORK TO RISK LIFE AND LIMB
AND TO YOU GUYS.
YOU ARE THE ONES RISKING YOUR
LIVES.
BY GOING OUT OF YOUR WAY TO
PROTECT AND IN SOME CASES RESCUE
THE MIGRANT, MORE OF THEM -- WE
DON'T INCENTIVIZE IT, WE TRY
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
WE DON'T WANT TO BECOME A
SERVICE.
IT IS A DAILY STRUGGLE THAT
THESE GUYS HAVE, BUT YOU CAN'T
LEAVE IN THE WATER.
YOU CAN'T LEAVE SOMEONE IN THE
WATER STRUGGLING.
>> HERE WE GO AGAIN ED MIGRANTS
THROWING THEMSELVES AND THE
RIO GRANDE.
THEY KNOW THEY WILL BE RESCUED
BECAUSE OTHERWISE, CARRIES THEM
STRAIGHT DOWN THE CURRENT, BUT
BORDER PATROL ALWAYS INTERVENES
AS THEY WILL NOW.
THIS GENTLEMAN, THIS LADY FROM
HONDURAS.
APPARENTLY, THERE ARE FRIENDS
THERE ON THE MEXICO MAINLAND
THAT HELP THEM GET ACROSS MEXICO
AND HERE TO THE RIO GRANDE.
AND NOW, THEY WILL GO IN FOR
PROCESS.
THE LADY CLAIMED SHE IS FROM
HONDURAS.
SHE SHOWED US CUTS ON HER ARM
AND HEAD TO.
DO YOU BELIEVE THIS MIGHT BE
PART OF A SCRIPT?
>> IT VERY WELL COULD BE.
WE SEE A LOT OF THE SAME
STORIES.
>> Raymond: DO YOU THINK THESE
PEOPLE PAID CARTEL TO GET HERE?
THEY ARE FROM HONDURAS.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU SEE THE TRAGEDY
IF THIS ALL AROUND WHERE A
FATHER, DAUGHTER JUMP INTO THE
RIVER THINKING THEY WERE GOING
TO GET SOME CLEMENCY COME A
BETTER LIFE.
THEY ARE NOW GOING TO BE TAKEN
AND PROCESSED AND EVENTUALLY
RELEASED IN THE COUNTRY BECAUSE
OF THE LAWS THE WAY THEY ARE.
BUT THEY PUT THEIR BELONGINGS